[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift we've
got a great show for you don't you know
great cast of characters as well
including these a cab driver who turned
into a hero for a veteran who was being
taken advantage of think about that also
two sisters who lost their mom then
faced even more sadness until strangers
joined together to help
and a high school baseball player who
didn't let anything come between him and
the game he loves and we do mean
anything also a 102 year old World War
II veteran finally getting some long
overdue recognition and a surprise phone
call there's David begno plus a baseball
team that goes bananas what makes them
so different from the rest we'll show
you we'll explain too all that plus our
top heartwarming videos the ones you
just need to see you're watching The
Uplift
[Music]
hey there I'm Tony decopo welcome once
again to the uplift here's a show that
lifts you up for at least the next 30
minutes ideally a little bit longer and
it's for you it's for me as well we're
going to start today with a video from a
recent wedding where you might expect to
see kids playing the role of flower girl
and ring bearer that's the typical
Arrangement but a bright name Brittany
wanted her cousin Marcus involved so
what you're looking at here is a flower
man and he got into the role he was
committed he danced down the aisle he
tossed those pedals and Brittany said he
definitely quote understood the
assignment nicely done
all right our next video shows a toddler
who could not contain his excitement
when he heard the garage door open
because he knew that meant a certain
someone was home take a look
[Music]
on the door tell him say Dada come on
Gaga
go knock on the door
[Music]
Bowie hush
come here
hey you
I missed you buddy guy oh that's little
Oliver Oliver's Dad is in the Army and
was away for a standard 10-day training
and that was the big return his mom kept
a little guy awake so he could get to
see Dad before he went to bed and as you
can see he was very excited to stay up
for that particular homecoming very
sweet stuff
all right moving on Landis Sims he's a
high school baseball player and he
doesn't let anything stop him from
playing the game he loves and now that
spirit is inspiring others here is Nancy
Chen with the story
sixteen-year-old Landis Sims is used to
swinging for the fences
Landis was born without hands in the
lower parts of his legs but that didn't
stop him from starting baseball at age
five your motto of just watch me what
does that mean you know people are gonna
doubt me so you know instead of me just
sitting there and talk to him and tell
him what I can do I'd just rather than
watch me and they did as land is
practiced with the Yankees when he was
10 and made the varsity team at his
Indiana high school last year using
specially designed equipment
he loves this game so much that he
wasn't going to listen to anybody else
now he's inspiring other children within
differences like 12 year old Chase
Merryweather who started playing
baseball after meeting Landis in 2016.
how important is it to have an example
like Landis it's important because like
if there's not an example I wouldn't be
here Landis wouldn't be here this whole
thing would have been happening right
now
with hopes of playing professionally one
day Landis says this is about More Than
Love of the Game I've learned you know
it's a game of failure and you know you
got to work through a mercy through
baseball but I work through diversity in
life every day an All-Star on and off
the field
baseball is life they say the rest is
just details well done Landis coming up
we'll show you another type of baseball
team the Savannah bananas what makes
them so unique we'll show you plus how
did a cab driver save an 82 year old
veteran in a vulnerable situation find
out after the break
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift my CBS
morning's co-host Nate Burleson likes to
say that not all heroes wear capes while
this next story proves that some Drive
cabs how did a driver help a vulnerable
82 year old veteran well CBS Sacramento
Steve large has the story
what was the first sign that something
was wrong
um we got a call and it was to go pick
up a friend he is a cab driver with no
no cape our red flags go off all the
time but Joel Carstens is being hailed a
hero well he got in the car and then
what happened as he showed me he had
eight thousand dollars cash he saved 82
year old Vietnam veteran Bill Miller he
wanted me to put twenty four hundred
dollars in this uh account from losing
thousands of dollars in a phone scam no
it was from um Publishers Warehouse so I
said well Bill what are we doing and he
says well there's you know he says about
Publishers Clearing House and so right
then I know exactly what was going on
the scam artists had set up the cab ride
counting on Carstens to deliver Miller
to a bank he'd never gone to before to
make a deposit in an account he'd never
set up before the promise millions of
dollars and a Mercedes and if anything
sounds too good to be true it is
Carstens took a detour and drove Miller
to Miller's Bank instead even walking
him inside the branch to talk to the
teller I told him he was a hero and when
I went in to the bank other people heard
what happened in that and came up and
shook his hand and said thank you very
much you said you know for helping this
Vietnam Vets hard-earned savings saved
by a conscientious cab driver don't fall
for this stuff if it sounds too good
it's bad
ain't that true all right NASA recently
released images from the James Webb
Telescope but some people got to see
those images of far off galaxies up
close real close CBS Sacramento is
Rachel wolf has a story
why do you like studying space so much
because I want to go to space
seven-year-old Sherman Sudbury wants to
be the next man on the moon how excited
are you like on a scale of one to ten
five thousand he was one of hundreds who
got a glimpse of the great beyond as Sac
State's planetarium teamed up with NASA
to release never-before-seen images from
the world's most powerful Space
Telescope so why come here to look at
these images you can check them out on
your phone but it's so much better when
you can see them on a 2500 square foot
Dome this is the perfect venue for
appreciating what NASA gave us today
Kyle Waters is the planetarium
coordinator leading visitors on a trip
to a galaxy far far away he says we've
previously seen images like this of the
Karina nebula where new stars are formed
but not in this great detail it's one of
the amazing things about this new James
Webb Space Telescope is its ability to
use infrared light almost like a form of
x-ray vision and it can peer through the
clouds of gas and dust on the enormous
screen he pointed out galaxies and
nebulas
and other planets outside the Earth's
solar system a million miles away when I
saw a line I'm like I'm like I'm like is
that like is that like a UFO line
Sherman not the only one who thought it
was awesome it left many Star Struck I
think it was cool
um you've seen new stuff that we haven't
seen before so for those of you
wondering if there really is life out
there just stare these new NASA images
giving you a reason to care about what's
up in the air
scientifically true we are all Stardust
or we began as such that's a great piece
there all right coming up a little girl
got just one just one RSVP to her
birthday party on top of that she was
already dealing with a loss so how did
social media and strangers help save the
day that's coming up plus a veteran who
served in an all-female all-black unit
during World War II is honored and
surprised
thank you
[Music]
there's a different kind of baseball
team entertaining fans in Savannah
Georgia how different and why well Chris
Van Cleave explains
it's baseball with a Twist a batter on
stilts or wearing kilts
here's a dancing umpire it might have
you thinking what's bananas
and you'd be right the viral video
sensation Savannah bananas are a
different Bunch by design team owner
Jesse Cole what is a baseball purist
think about what you're doing baseball
purists don't love what we do but we're
not for them we're for people that want
to come out and have fun
banana ball is a bit PT Barnum meets the
Harlem Globetrotters at a dance party
Cole tweaked the rules to amp up the
action making for plenty of viral appeal
like Kyle lug's Reuben pre-pitched dance
viewed over 43 million times on tick
tock
oh
it blows my mind it's insane to think
about try and do it again see what you
can do next to get more
every game is a sellout with a ripening
waiting list 65 000 fans long the
runners drove 11 and a half hours from
Ohio Major League Baseball is not quite
anything like this it's boring so we are
very excited to be down here
perhaps most striking for two hours fans
eyes were not on their phones but on the
field no need for social media when the
viral moments happen right in front of
you
our next story is about an
eight-year-old girl who just suffered a
terrible loss and then had to try to
celebrate her birthday that can be
tricky what could have been a
devastating day though turned into a
beautiful one Caitlin O'Kane has the
story
Chloe Sexton and her little sister
Charlotte lost their mom this year to
cancer Chloe is 20 years older than her
sister she's always been like a second
mom to Charlotte now she was her
guardian brief is wave after wave of
first
um the month of May is her birthday my
baby's birthday and brain cancer
awareness month
um so I thought you know the worst of
the first had come but my little
sister's birthday I hadn't really
anticipated how much that would hurt
their mom battled brain cancer for most
of Charlotte's life undergoing five
surgeries over 11 years so Charlotte
wasn't accustomed to celebrating her
birthday with a big party Charlotte had
to move to a new school and her big
sister wanted to throw her a party for
her upcoming eighth birthday Chloe sent
out invitations to Charlotte's new
classmates and was disappointed by the
response
my little sister turns eight tomorrow
her birthday party is going to be
this weekend
um
our mom died of brain cancer 83 days ago
one one child from her class RCP her
whole class knew what happened okay
Chloe who has a following on social
media posted about it on Tick Tock and
the story went viral followers started
conversations in the comments
coordinating with each other on how they
could help out
the most help that I got locally I
started getting through Instagram so um
fellow moms who were finding out that
they lived the same city as me um who
said you know I have a kid the same age
Charlotte can we come to the party I got
at least a dozen of those and every one
of them of course they said yes yes he
can come to the party please come to the
party
um and then there was
a woman
um named Libby and she has a 22 year old
horse named uh Miss Gracie and she asked
you know can I bring her pony rides I
said yes pretty much I just kept saying
yes so it became this
enormous party
um but obviously the most helpful thing
was the women who were reaching out to
me saying can I help you set up for the
party can I come to your house and help
you set up and clean your house and it
was just yes you can absolutely
Charlotte had no clue what was going on
behind the scenes
I did not I didn't tell her anything
about
um
the kid's not coming I only focused on
who was coming so I told her you're
going to meet a lot of new kids today
and it's gonna be amazing and you're
gonna have the best birthday of your
life I promise you
so I didn't tell her anything that was
gonna happen that day also just in case
you know Miss Gracie the pony got a flat
tire or something
um I didn't want any of the
disappointments to be focused on that
day
um but a lot of it was a surprise to me
as well Charlotte said the party was
even more beautiful than she could have
imagined
both sisters made friends that day it
doesn't completely fill the hole left by
their mom but now they know they have
each other and a whole community of
support I feel like it became something
that was so much more than a birthday
party
um
my sister went to therapy this morning
actually and something that she had said
was um
none of the day was sad it was all very
very happy I do wish that mommy had been
here but it was so so so happy and
that's
all I was really looking for was it not
to be a day where she was focused and
sad about
um
what she wasn't going to have because
mom was gone it may have been
Charlotte's birthday but the party meant
a lot to Chloe I think it changed my
life I think it
saved something in me which was that
[Music]
it can be isolating in itself to be on
social media and to never actually meet
the people or see the people who comment
on your life and on your grief
um it can feel like none of it's real
like people will say nice things but do
they ever really know you or do they
ever really care and this was the first
time that I ever saw people all over the
world see an opportunity to show me that
they cared about me and they saw me and
to make it happen so that I didn't feel
alone
it's very sweet coming up more sweetness
David begno introduces us to a World War
II veteran who received long overdue
recognition and a surprise phone call
who's on the other end of that line find
out after the break
[Music]
we are now going to introduce you to
cresencia Garcia she's 102 years old and
she is one of the last surviving members
of an all-female all-black unit that
served in England during World War II
our David bagno picks up the story
it's kind of crazy two years ago I
received a message from Tara Garcia hi
David she told me that her grandmother
cresencia had beaten covet at the age of
100. now that was at the beginning of
the pandemic and we all needed good news
then so I tweeted about it and included
pictures that Tara had sent to me one of
which included her grandmother in a
military uniform I just knew that she
was a veteran and that she was in the
Army and that she was very proud that
tweet went viral and it was seen by
retired army colonel Edna Cummings it
was like being in a casino and hitting
the jackpot she started connecting some
dots and reached out to Garcia's family
she spoke to Tara she says let's start
here give me her dog tag numbers and
we'll compare them as it turns out she
was in a burn unit about 30 kilometers
from Birmingham England treating
soldiers because it was such a Manpower
shortage all over you know year Europe
get this cresencia Garcia is one of only
six surviving members of an all-female
all-black segregated unit that was sent
overseas during World War II known as
the six Triple Eight the 855 women that
served in that unit are now receiving
long overdue recognition they are the
only military women's unit to receive
the Congressional gold medal
they are part of an elite group of less
than 200 recipients the first being
General George Washington and I was just
like you got to be kidding me and
everything matched up and I looked at my
parents and it's like I think we just
opened Pandora's Box here they sure did
they found out that Miss Garcia's name
is on a monument at Fort Leavenworth in
Kansas now as the families finding out
about all this I had no clue I never
heard from Tara again
I got a call from the good Folks at
Oprah daily in fact I was here at home
and they said David we were just pitched
about a story involving a 102 year old
woman who served during World War II and
her family is only now learning stories
that they've never heard before so my
team said we got to do something so they
called Tara
and we had a surprise may I say hello
oh dude how are you
I have wanted to meet you
surprise
okay
[Music]
oh the pleasure is mine the pleasure is
mine you don't understand
you don't understand well I came to
listen
hi oh
okay I'm so
it's okay I I feel the same miss
chrysencia my name is David David hi
David hi it's very nice to meet you it's
an honor actually to meet you it is
especially you
she enlisted in the U.S army at the age
of 24 after being enraged by the bombing
of Pearl Harbor
the Army Center to Texas for basic
training this would mean the black
section and that is the white section
um
see
yes America to you
and it's very sad you know
very sad I want to talk about your
service
it wasn't right it wasn't much no I was
just a medic you were a medic yeah I was
just to take care of the hurt the hurt
you know when they came in I took care
of them thank you for your service
you're welcome I am proud to be an
American what is this moment like for
you I am delighted that everyone gets to
see what I see
because some people don't they don't get
it until you actually experience it and
see it you don't live to be 102 without
being a sparkler I mean
right you're full of life
he said 102. oh my God
you just reminded her oh yes because
you'll be my grandson
oh you look great you look great thank
you
[Music]
Mrs Garcia was born in Puerto Rico on
April 18 1920.
a loaf of bread cost you 12 cents then
Woodrow Wilson was the president and
women didn't have the right to vote when
World War II began she told us she had
already moved to New York City and felt
a patriotic duty to serve her country
after the war she married Esteban Garcia
II an army veteran himself they raised
three children in the Bronx she spent
her post-war work years working as a
seamstress and a pattern maker in New
York City's garment district
her husband died in 1994 after 47 years
of marriage that's my grandfather let me
see this handsome man now we had
arranged for a little surprise for Mrs
Garcia but the surprise timeline was a
little off and she was getting a little
restless so what were we going to do you
want Scotch
I have Daddy Walker Johnny Walker you
want you want one yeah
does she really can we cheers a toast a
toast to you to me at 102. thank you
finally the phone rang so I have one
other surprise for you can you answer
that please
[Music]
hello Tara
hey how are you it's Jill Biden how are
you doing hi
I'm great how are you I'm great too I
hear you have a very special grandmother
I do I do hello Hi it's Jill Biden oh
you're the one that needs to be
celebrated you are one incredible woman
and I can't thank you enough for all
your service to our country and I salute
you
keep it up keep up with a good word
I'm trying to follow in your footsteps
and in your example thank you thank you
Tara for sharing this moment with me and
with all of America thank you so much
really nice to meet you take care love
you Mrs Garcia's memory is fading but
let me tell you in that moment she was
fully present how amazing was that
the fact that she knew who that was yeah
and she felt that that acknowledgment
just now
that's all I needed that's all I needed
and I I just want her to remember that's
all
and that's all I needed as well that
dear viewer is our show I hope it
brightened your day and lifted you up
I'm confident that it did if it didn't
though by the way you can re-watch it
re-watches are free see you next time on
the uplift
[Music]